[Musique]
montceau a ravi de vous retrouver pour
ce nouveau numéro de 7,8 échos le
magazine consacré à l'actualité
économique de notre territoire voici le
sommaire avec l'augmentation à ces
dernières années des attaques
informatiques la filière liés à la
cybersécurité s'est fortement développée
sur le territoire de saint quentin en
yvelines
on y retrouve des leaders mondiaux comme
atos ou des plus petites structures
comme al métis un focus ce dans ce
numéro sur une jeune entreprise exode
games à la choisi l'espace de cowher
king stop and work à montigny le
bretonneux pour développer ses jeux de
société et des locaux flambant neufs
pour que ligan france l'inauguration
d'un fab lab à l'estaca ou encore la
générosité d'un patron de poissy nous
ferons le point sur le reste de
l'actualité économique dans notre
département
et puis jean michel fourgous président
de l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines sera avec nous en plateau pour
évoquer la politique la police politique
pardon numérique et de cybersécurité
mené sur notre territoire mais avant de
développer tous ces thèmes ouvrons ce
magazine avec un chiffre plus 48%
c'est la progression de cyberattaques
observée en 2010 est une cyberattaque
c'est un acte malveillant vers un
dispositif informatique 92 % des
entreprises ont été visés l'année
dernière une ou plusieurs fois et c'est
pourquoi ces dernières années de
nombreuses sociétés se sont spécialisés
dans la cybersécurité
plusieurs d'entre elles se situent sur
notre territoire nous y reviendrons en
détail dans et quelques minutes mais
tout de suite focus sur une toute jeune
entreprise exode games elle a choisi de
développer ses jeux de société au sein
du nouvel espace de coworking top à new
york à montigny le bretonneux reportage
univers post apocalyptique où décalé
avec des gobelins âgé de tout juste six
mois l'entreprise exode games composé de
trois salariés développe des jeux de
société dont ses bureaux particularité
ils sont installés au sein de stopper
works un espace de coworking à montigny
le bretonneux pour des jeunes sociétés
on nous offre des services de équivalent
des grands comme un standard
téléphonique une
l'utilisation du courrier et on a la
possibilité surtout avec certaines
marques de s'étendre
on a commencé on avait que deux bureaux
aujourd'hui on en a trois donc c'est
petit à petit on pourra s'étendre si on
veut prendre plus de bureau plus des
stages les plateaux de jeux cartes et
figurines sont conçus et fabriqués sur
place de référence seront bientôt
disponibles
on pourra trouver des gobeline à d'un
jeu destiné à un public familial en
septembre prochain en magasins dès le
mois d'octobre
after ziad un jeu experts fera l'objet
d'une campagne de financement
participatif des gobelins en boutique
on compte le faire à 30 euros tandis que
l'acteur diène étant donné qu'on passe
par la plateforme de financement
participatif kickstarter les bikers nous
pourrons
eux-mêmes jauger ce qu'ils donneront
s'ils veulent tout simplement soutenir
le projet à hauteur de 10 euros 20 euros
ou s'ils veulent soutenir le projet et
en plus recevoir le produit
donc là il faudra pour te raconter sur
une centaine d'euros objectif pour la
jeune société au cours des trois
prochaines années
proposer encore plus de références et
tripler son chiffre d'affaires présence
du numérique dont les entreprises ont
encore la forte croissance des objets
connectés a eu comme effet ces dernières
années d'augmenter le nombre de
cyberattaques
l'occasion donc de faire un point sur
les entreprises spécialisés dans la
cybersécurité et à sont nombreux sur
notre territoire comme vous allez le
voir dans ce reportage
espionnage vol de données sabotages ces
dernières années le nombre d' attaques
informatiques s'est considérablement
accéléré les entreprises de plus en plus
digitalisées sont les premières victimes
de ces cyber attaques
elle saint quentin en yvelines est l'un
des rares territoires d'île de france a
disposé d'une filière cybersécurité on y
retrouve des leaders mondiaux comme atos
900 personnes travaillent sur le site
historique des clayes-sous-bois c'est
ici dans ce centre de recherche et
développement que naissent les
technologies de protection des systèmes
d'informations aujourd'hui dans nos
centres de supervision gère peu près 150
millions d'événements par heure c'est
phénoménal 3.5 millions d'objets
connectés et sont sécurisés par
aujourd'hui par atos et quand je parle
objets collectés je fais référence à des
véhicules collectés je fais référence à
des compteurs intelligents référence à
tous les réseaux mobiles qui vont
connecter des compteurs avec un chiffre
d'affaires de 12 milliards d'euros atos
emploie cent mille personnes dans 73
pays du monde
en plus de ses activités de recherche et
développement le site saint quentinois
accueil à l'automne prochain à un
nouveau datacenter un support pour
l'hébergement des données de ses clients
on travaille beaucoup avec des grands
groupes qui s'y mènent ce philips
aux etats unis aussi ranxerox qu'ont
acquis aussi il ya quelques années où
l'appareil on héberge énormément de
grands clients américains et en france
en particulier c'est vrai qu'on est
aussi fortement implanté dans les
collectivités et dans les ministères on
travaille beaucoup avec le ministère de
la défense
la partie bien sûr cybersécurité pour la
sécurité de leurs données les
entreprises doivent donc aujourd'hui se
faire accompagner par des experts en
cybersécurité à guyancourt par exemple
depuis dix ans à le métis est
spécialisée dans la sécurisation des
documents électroniques et travaille
pour des grands groupes mais aussi des
tpe et des pme
nous proposons par exemple des solutions
de
dématérialisation à valeur probante ont
typiquement de signature électronique de
documents en masse pour la signature des
factures clients
demain par exemple de la société suez
aux france donc les 20 millions de
factures clients sont authentifiés
sécurisé avec nos systèmes
la petite société gère actuellement un
portefeuille de 500 clients et a vu ce
nombre augmenter ces dernières années
globalement de nous avons senti à partir
on va dire de 2011 avec un accélérateur
en 2016 une hausse une croissance de
notre
de la demande en fait pour des solutions
de sécurité avec ses leaders mondiaux et
ses pépites françaises le territoire de
saint quentin en yvelines semble avoir
pris une longueur d'avancé dans le
domaine de la cyber sécurité
émargeant sur ce plateau jean michel
fourgous bonsoir mes shows 1
vous êtes le président de saint quentin
en yvelines alors on vient de le voir un
autre territoire regorge d'entreprises
liées au numérique à la cybersécurité
comment expliquez vous cela
eh bien d'abord parce que vous êtes dans
les yvelines vous êtes dans paris saclay
saint quentin et le choeur économie de
paris saclay qui est le premier
réservoir de cerveaux français
aujourd'hui vous êtes en même temps dans
d'une société qui a la plus forte
accélération par la transformation
numérique
vous avez lu numérique c'est le plus
grand des multiplicateurs d'intelligence
d'innovation et de croissance jamais
inventée par l'homme depuis sa naissance
donc on est bien sûr dans les
entreprises de transformation numérique
à fond plus robotisation bien sûr des
chaînes de production ce qui augmente
massivement les besoins de cyber
sécurité
la cybersécurité aujourd'hui c'est un
marché sur les cinq ans d'après les
spécialistes un chiffre hors normes on
parle de 1000 milliards d'euros sur cinq
ans vous imaginer pourquoi parce que le
numérique rentre partout bien sûr dans
tous les domaines santé éducation le
vois je voudrais d'elancourt à saint
quentin
aujourd'hui les enfants apprennent
complètement différemment et on
travaille différemment ou voyagent
différemment on mange différemment
surveillent ce que l'on mange
enfin c'est ont fait de la gymnastique
mais on surveille son corps on surveille
son alimentation
ces relations sont travail en organise
son travail le télétravail kariba donc
aujourd'hui bien sûr le numérique envahi
tous les secteurs et donc se pose la
question
dans à saint quentin on a les plus gros
enfin c'est surtout en cybersécurité
bien sûr on a on a ce talent s
tel est ce qui vient d'absorber une
grosse entreprise qui va en faire en
fait quasiment le numéro un c'est
gemalto donc en absorbant gemalto qui
m'intéressent devient un des leaders
mondiaux de la cybersécurité vous avez à
vous avez des plus gros vous avez sur
les dix les 10 gros français vous en
avez cinq 5 qui sont à 51 dont est
évident qu'il ya un savoir faire il ya
atos vous l'avez montré tout à l'heure à
tout ce qui est qui fabrique un
ordinateur qui fait un milliard de
milliards d'opérations d'une seconde
devant vous imaginez dans quel univers
en est et est bien sûr malheureusement
ça génère cette réussite cette
démultiplication de l'intelligence
extraordinaire ça bien sûr ça suscite
des toujours des comportements
indélicats et et donc des cyberattaques
comme on dit qui coûte très cher aux
entreprises et aujourd'hui
vu l'intensité de tous ces réseaux
informatiques qui en fait sont un rôle
très important dans le monde entier
bien entendu il ya une génération notre
savoir faire sur la contre attaque entre
milieux où la protection des données
effectivement les entreprises de saint
quentin sont particulièrement connus
pour cela pour une une excellence
de haute technologie en relation
d'ailleurs avec des grandes écoles
brillante que l'on a dans paris saclay
des laboratoires très brillant des
entreprises donc partie des leaders
mondiaux dont je vous rappelle que on
est en été classés dans les huit zones
mondiales les plus innovantes au monde
donc bien sûr on a la chance d'avoir
tous ces grands spécialistes des
entreprises qui ont une forte croissance
et vous l'avez montré tout à l'heure les
cyber attaques ont progressé de près de
50 % sur une année
donc aujourd'hui c'est pas simplement
une crise de paranoïa aiguë d'un
entrepreneur c'est en plus ça touche les
pays au début il y avait des petites
attaques demandant des rançons
aujourd'hui c'est des attaques qui
attaque tout un tout une entreprise ou
bien tout un pays
donc on est osé lui dire les relations
qu'il ya eu assez tendues entre les
etats-unis la russie des présomptions
aussi sur sur la corée du nord
donc voilà aujourd'hui on doit intégrer
ça aa aux obligations diplomatiques en
tout cas nos ingénieurs on a de très
bons ingénieurs générique dernière
création ce que cet entretien a tous
bientôt à sa fin jean michel fourgous
vous l'avez évoqué tout à l'heure donc
la cybersécurité ça un secteur d'avenir
finalement comment ça se fait que les
entreprises n'arrivent pas bien à
recruter finalement avec toutes les
entreprises de cyber sécurité qui sont
sur notre territoire apparemment ils ont
du mal à recruter comment ça se fait il
ya effectivement à saint quentin il ya
dix mille emplois par exemple qui ont
pas suffisamment été satisfait parce que
on a un déficit aujourd'hui en france et
même nous donc on est obligé
d'intensifier les formations on a fait
venir cette école privée supplémentaire
donc 55 labellisé mission pour que les
jeunes ont une intensification leur
formation et de certification est
également l'université de saint quentin
aussi augmentant niveau audience qui est
assez drôle c'est que le président pour
la première fois dans l'histoire de
l'université de 50 ans le nouveau
président vient directement
numérique et donc il ya aussi des
formations qui monte en puissance à
saint quentin et tout cela dans dandy
dans paris saclay où vous avez des très
belles écoles d'ingénieurs des très
belles de l'école ja de techniciens et
donc vous lie à et je dirais une un
vivier culturel numérique très favorable
bien sûr pour prendre les meilleures
positions mondiales je pense sur ce
marché en pleine croissance
merci jean michel fourgous d'être venu
sur notre plateau je rappelle que vous
êtes le président de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines voilà cette
émission touche déjà à sa fin
merci de l'avoir suivi c'est d'ailleurs
le dernier numéro de la saison
vous pouvez je vous rappelle revoir tous
bien sûr les 7-8 échos sur notre site
internet www.tv5monde.com à très bientôt
[Musique]